elsewhere Russia has bombarded Ukraine
with major airstrikes for the second
time in three days Ukrainian officials
say 34 people were wounded with their
Raid Sirens ringing out across the
country including in a capital cave
or joining me now is our security and
defense analyst Professor Michael Clarke
and Michael what do we know then about
these strikes uh well this is the 16th
strike since last October uh not such a
big one uh there were 18 cruise missiles
launched from aircraft flying within the
Russian airspace and ukrainians say that
they shot down 15 of them which is
plausible but they certainly did some
damage and over the there was a smaller
airstrike a couple of days ago that
killed some people today about 30 odd
injured and a big hit of pavagrad which
the Russians have claimed in which the
ukrainians are confirming and the point
about it is that um the Russians say
that they hit an ammunition dump near
the railway uh yard there and the
ukrainians say well it was a chemical
Factory which is quite nearby certainly
it's not a straightforward explosion
from this bit of film that we've got
because you can see the secondary
explosions going off which is
personalized with some ammunition or
with maybe chemicals and fuel that may
have been being used at the chemical
plant so either is plausible but
undoubtedly the Russians think that they
are targeting the uh the basis of the
Ukrainian war effort for the offense of
which the ukrainians are waiting to
launch sometime in the next few weeks
and what does this tell us
tell us cranes air defenses well they're
quite good but they're probably going to
start running out of missiles if they're
not careful I mean they use the S 300 at
the moment which is the old Soviet
system but they're using about 200
missiles a month and so they're going to
run short of of the ammunition for that
now they're getting these things Patriot
batteries these are in Poland at the
moment that these particular ones and it
will take some time for them to be
deployed because they require a lot of
training and they're very expensive and
these will shoot down anything but
equally but the ukrainians won't want to
use very expensive Patriot missiles
against the cheap drone and so on and
the Russians I think have a strategy of
attacking the ukrainians to make them
use up as much ammunition as possible
because they know that Ukrainian
ammunition is if anything more limited
than Russian ammunition is even with the
shortages that sanctions have created
and we've also been talking about Sudan
we've looked at we've seen a situation
unfolding there and we know that there
have been some ceasefires very fragile
from your perspective what are the
chances of this currencies fire there's
in place holding
yes and well we're into the fourth
ceasefire now and there may be more but
the inherent situation in Sudan is not
very favorable because the Wagner group
who are active of course in Russia the
the mercenary group that work for the
Kremlin they're very act they're very
active in Libya and they are with
they're working with hafta who is the
Breakaway General in Libya and the and
they're they're working with him and
they have some power in in the uh the
border between Libya and Sudan they're
very active in Chad
um and again they're they're offering uh
the rsf the the more the rebel of the
two groups the two uh military groups
that are fighting they're offering them
weapons maybe through Chad they're very
strong the Wagner group in the Central
African Republic and one of the things
that they're very interested in Darfur
this whole area of Darfur which 20 years
ago was the scene of a genocidal Civil
War there's a lot of gold in Darfur a
lot of gold mines and the uh the Wagner
group would love to get their hands
through the rsf through their client on
some of the rights of those gold mines
already they have cut they've companies
that put their money into the UAE the
United Emirates they've got they've got
lots of interest there and so there's a
lot of Gulf interest in what goes on the
Saudis are trying to calm the whole
thing down the United Arab Emirates have
a stake with the rsf one of the two
generals who are fighting so it doesn't
look very good because the the Sudan is
the center of a lot of regional
instability one of the most useful areas
might be south of this map Kenya the
Kenyan president routine the new Kenyan
president is would love to be a mediator
is trying to mediate and the Kenyans
might have some influence with the
Saudis in trying to hold this thing
together but it will be difficult and
it's really it's a it's a competition
between two military generals I mean we
know that the next ruler of Sudan is
going to be a brutal military dictator
and they're competing between themselves
the hamiti and bulhan are competing as
to who shall be that brutal military
dictator be one of the other if it's if
it's uh hamiti then the Wagner group
will have a hold on Sudan that will be
very bad if it's this man it won't be
very pleasant but it's probably a bit
more capable of being damped down by the
uh by the community but we'll see what
happens in the next couple of weeks